MIKE WILUSZ: Welcome
to Cloud OnAir,
live webinars from Google Cloud.
We are hosting
webinars every Tuesday.
My name is Mike Wilusz.
And today, we will be talking
about how to enhance your G
Suite efficiency with Chrome.
You can ask questions
any time on the platform.
We have Googlers on
standby to answer them.
Let's get started.
First, I want to
talk a little bit
about the evolution
of enterprise
and where end-user
computing has come to today.
Today's movement we
call the cloud movement.
But it actually starts way
back when we were originally
talking about mainframes.
In the 1990s, [INAUDIBLE]
became more powerful
with the rise of
the PC movement.
So everyone started
to get computers
on their desks, which
were more powerful
than the traditional
mainframe workstations they
were working with.
This also brought
the rise of software.
So end users began to install
packaged software directly
on their workstations.
This also led to an increase
in the need for software
from a security standpoint.
So this now required the likes
of things like anti-virus
and firewalls to be installed
directly on these workstations.
And then starting in
2000 with the rise
of the internet movement, we saw
more and more computing power
being brought to the cloud
and was really the beginning
of the cloud movement.
As we transition
through the 2000s,
end users became
more and more mobile.
So this meant that users now had
more power that they had access
from from their actual
phones versus what
they were traditionally
using on their desktops.
This was also the rise
of the social movement.
So end users expected to
become more collaborative.
They expected
inherently that as I
start to use tools to
work with my colleagues
that I would be able to
just inherently collaborate
without the need to
install desktop software.
Continuing through the 2000s,
we actually saw a greater rise
in applications.
And this is where we
started to see people start
to bring tablets
to the enterprise,
expecting that they
would constantly
have access and
access to the content
that they need with this
tremendous wealth of power
of computing in the back end.
And now, here we are today
in the cloud movement.
And the interesting part
is that we haven't really
seen a transition from
the PC computing age.
We're still seeing a lot of
people with plain workstations
with operating systems on
top of those platforms.
They have to continue to
install security software.
So as we've seen a transition of
data to the cloud and computing
to the cloud, we actually
haven't fundamentally
changed how we have end users
access that compute resource.
But think about what you're
already doing with your G Suite
investment.
You're already
adopting the cloud
to give yourself a
competitive advantage.
A great stat is 70% of
forward-thinking companies
on Forbes' Cloud 100 list
are active G Suite customers.
Many of you are on
this webcast today.
Think about some of the
value that that's driving
for today for your end users.
There's inherent intelligence
inside of these applications.
Whether you're using Gmail
with suggested replies
or you're using our brand
new Hangouts chat product,
you have access to a wealth
of artificial intelligence
capabilities built directly
in to these applications
without requiring that your
users are installing software
directly onto workstations.
There is a natural
culture of collaboration
that comes with G Suite.
The users are naturally
looking to share content
with each other.
And they're expecting that
those connections will just
happen inherently on
top of the platform.
They're not thinking about the
devices that they're using.
They're just looking at
being able to reach out
to their colleagues
to get answers.
Connected knowledge
is, I want to be
able to search for the
content no matter where I am,
when I want access to that.
Google Drive has really driven
a large innovation there,
where you have the
ability to access
this content on your mobile
device or on your desktop
and, again, bringing
the capabilities
of artificial intelligence
to do things like
suggest documents for you
to work on the first time
that you access your Drive.
And then simple and secure
manageability-- as you know,
the entire control
panel for G Suite
is managed directly
within the Google Cloud.
And this allows you to
not have to be concerned
about security capabilities.
It's inherent to the platform.
And we allow you to have a
level of controls from sharing
everything publicly
that you want
your users to be able to
share all the way to very
fine-tuned data controls
to allow you to ensure
that your users are
not sharing data
outside the bounds
of your organization.
So you're already getting a
lot of the advantages of cloud
by already being on G Suite.
But again, traditionally,
we're seeing a lot of customers
are continuing to leverage
existing workstations.
And we think there's
an opportunity for us
to innovate with our customers
to drive new types of business
advantages.
And we truly believe
that the cloud
is the spot where we're going
to help you be able to innovate
from a security perspective.
We're finding more and more
organizations are absolutely
adopting more and more
applications inside the cloud,
whether it's things like G
Suite leveraging collaboration
capabilities, to
ERP capabilities,
to things like Salesforce from
a CRM perspective, all the way
to popular HR providers.
We're seeing more and
more organizations
adopt these platforms to become
a cloud-first organization
to take advantage of
the security innovations
in the cloud to put their most
sensitive data, like CRM and HR
data, into these secure,
cloud-based tools.
What we're finding is
because of this access
to cloud-based
applications, users
are expecting more
and more that they
want to be able to
access these applications
and use their capabilities
no matter where they are.
So what that means is they want
to be able to-- whether I'm
sitting on a Windows desktop
or I'm actively using my iPhone
or I'm sitting currently
on an Android tablet,
I want to have the
same capabilities
and be highly mobile.
And what we've
traditionally seen
is many of these endpoints
aren't necessarily
catered to that experience.
But we're finding more and more
applications are allowing users
to bring these
capabilities no matter
which device they want to use.
And unfortunately, the
number of security attacks
is on the rise, and they're
becoming absolutely more
and more advanced.
We're seeing a great rise in
things like phishing attacks
and targeted phishing attacks
called "spearphishing."
We're also seeing a
rise sort of malware.
I just saw a recent
article that was discussing
the rise of ransomware in
a recent municipality where
they actually had to send
their employees home.
So already, hackers
know that there
is a target by leveraging the
existing endpoints out there.
They know that there is a vector
to get into organizations.
And they're leveraging
that to then springboard
into other applications
that may be in the cloud.
So we think this is a
really great opportunity
to actually address the
endpoint security strategy.
But what we have
found-- legacy endpoints
are really not built
to support security
and certainly have
not transitioned well
into the modern computing age.
You think about your phone when
you're using an application.
When's the last time you thought
about things like a firewall
on your phone or you've
thought about the capabilities
of anti-virus updates?
We traditionally, on
next-generation computing
platforms, don't really
think about that stuff.
But we're very used to, from an
end-user computing perspective,
putting an endpoint
out there and having
to think about this entire
strategy every single time.
And as organizations are making
the transition to Windows 10,
we have to consider
this all over again.
So whether it's partnering
with a virus vendor,
worrying about software updates
that we have to deal with,
sometimes very last minute as
next generation attacks come
out, patching that
operating system--
the transition of Windows
7 to Windows 10 is a very,
very large transition for
customers that a lot of them
are taking their time with--
upgrading hardware-- getting
a new piece of hardware
means you have to
create new images.
And then how do you backup
this data that is not currently
being based within the cloud?
You have to figure out the
strategies and even things
like encryption as well.
And we think this
is the opportunity
to take a look at what
we offer with Chrome
OS and the capabilities we offer
to our enterprise customers.
And let's think about it.
Organizations are
driven to say, I
want these two strategies
to be combined.
I want my organization
to be more collaborative,
to absolutely embrace
next-generation security using
the capabilities of the cloud.
But I don't want to be concerned
about endpoint security.
I'm not in the
business of needing
to lock down my workstations.
So organizations are coming
to Google and saying,
there must be a
strategy around this,
around giving our users
next-generation endpoints
that they absolutely can
fall in love with and be
able to leverage those
to securely access tools,
whether they're on G Suite or
other cloud-based applications
out there.
And that's exactly
where Chrome Enterprise
comes into the picture.
Customers often ask us what is
the difference between Chrome
Enterprise and Chrome OS.
And Chrome Enterprise
is the offering
that we have for both management
and support of Chrome OS
devices.
So the Chrome OS devices that
you can use as an enterprise
are the same ones that
you could purchase
from your existing
hardware vendors
or go out to your
favorite electronics store
and purchase those.
And by applying the
Chrome Enterprise license,
you now have the capabilities
to fully control and manage
that cloud-based endpoint and
pass down security policies
and access a set of
applications that you
want to dictate to your user.
And we've done many
advancements specifically
in the Enterprise
for our customers
to make sure they're
getting the capabilities
that they need out
of the platform.
We've increased the amount
of productivity apps
that are currently
available on the platform.
Traditionally, it just
was web-based applications
and Chrome applications.
We've now extended that
ecosystem to the Android Play
Store as well, giving
us full capability
to now install applications
directly on these endpoints
and then also offer
updated applications
as they come to the Play Store.
Built-in security
protection's directly in,
which we'll talk a
little bit of later on.
But something unique to
this platform versus what
you may see from the competitors
or some of the other offerings
out there is that we directly
update the operating systems
right from Google.
So that means whether you're
working with Dell, HP, Lenovo,
whoever your favorite vendor
is, you can continue to leverage
those endpoints that your users
absolutely fall in love with.
But you're actually getting
direct OS updates from Google.
So that means you don't have
to worry about those vendors
having to certify
a patch before it's
released to your endpoints.
And this is more
and more important
as we're seeing more and
more zero-day attacks being
offered out there.
The great part is
that it is tightly
integrated to your
existing G Suite console--
optionally tightly integrated,
which we'll talk about a little
later on.
What this means is
you can actually
manage your entire
fleet of devices.
So we're talking hundreds
if not tens of thousands
of devices directly managed
from your G Suite console.
All that requires is the
purchase of a Chrome Enterprise
license.
And then you then
have the capabilities
of managing all the policies
directly on that device.
And automatic updates come with
support directly from Google
as well.
So that means if you
ever run into an issue,
whether it's a hardware
issue or a software issue
and you need to reach out to
Google for support on these,
you get direct 24/7, 365 support
from Google Cloud support team
to guide you through any
issues that you're having.
And we think by combining
these two platforms together
that you'll get truly
next-generation security
capabilities.
Piece of mind multi-layered
security means that you have
the capabilities to--
no matter what, whether
it's a piece of hardware
or a piece of software--
be able to make sure that the
policies are truly locking down
the device and
making sure that you
don't have to be
concerned about,
oh, I have to update
the anti-virus.
Oh, I have to update the
firewall on top of this.
Hassle-free management--
built-in management directly
from Google's cloud
for this platform.
That means that from a
management perspective,
you're going to the same
console that you're using today.
And you're getting more value
from the existing management
platform that you're
used to with less cost--
and we'll talk about that a
little later on from an ROI
perspective-- and a
consistent experience,
no matter the type of
device you're using,
whether it's a
Chrome OS Chromebook
or you're using a Chromebox,
the same exact experience
for your end users no
matter where they sit
and which types of devices
they're currently using.
So let's talk a little bit
about the protections that
come inherent to the platform.
You get automatic security
updates directly from Google.
That means when that next
generation of vulnerability
comes out, you'll come
directly to Google support
for assistance.
And those updates
will come directly
from the Google Cloud
delivered directly down
to your endpoints.
Things that you're possibly
used to from the Chrome browser
capabilities, but the
ability to actually isolate
individual processes--
this is a lot
of what you see on a lot
of modern mobile platforms
as well.
So this is essentially processes
cannot read data from each
other.
That allows them
to run isolated.
So if there was
ever a vulnerability
to a single application,
it wouldn't bleed over
to the rest of the
operating system
or to other applications
currently running
on that device.
And then other
browser technology
that you're possibly used to,
things like Safe Browsing--
so leveraging Google's cloud
to see if there's any nefarious
websites that your users are
going to and preventing them
from directly accessing
them on those devices--
and then also
secure app access--
so making sure the applications
that your users are accessing
are delivered from a web
store or from the Play Store.
So they've gone
through security audits
before they're
actually delivered.
Users cannot side load
executables onto these devices
to be able to get around
security controls that you put
on them.
And a reduced TCO--
we're really driving down
the price of these devices,
finding a spot where we
think that enterprises will
be able to use these at
scale at a price point that's
not like many of the other
platforms that they're used to.
Low end-user support costs--
because these devices are very
easy to wipe, very shareable,
we think it's a
great opportunity
to also lower the support costs.
Think of the time that
goes into OS management
having to reimage a device.
This is time that it costs you
from a support perspective.
And we think by
leveraging this platform,
you'll have these
capabilities built directly in
and a future-proof solution.
So as we continue to make
innovations on Chrome OS,
as we continue to add new
capabilities like the Google
Assistant, these will be
available to you as a customer.
And you'll be able to leverage
these at your discretion,
leveraging the control panel.
So that means that
it doesn't require
that you have to go out there,
buy a new device that supports
that new operating system.
You're getting direct
support from Google
for these devices
for years to come.
And a lot of the
controls and permissions
that you're used to today
would also carry over
to the Chrome OS devices.
So you can really have great
filter policy and controls
that you're putting
on these users.
So this can be every
restriction from disabling users
from going into
an incognito mode
to actually controlling
USB port access.
And these are as
simple as check boxes
directly in the control
panel, leveraging
a lot of the management
capability you're used to,
like organizational units.
You could set
sign-in restrictions
to ensure that users are only
using the device that you
want them to use.
So this restricts
users from logging in,
let's say, their personal Gmail
account to actually access
the Chromebook.
You can actually restrict
it to just your enterprise.
And then whitelisting
and blacklisting
of applications-- so ensuring
that your users are only
installing the applications
from stores that you want
them to be able to install.
So we have full whitelist
and blacklist capabilities,
all the way down to the Android
capabilities that we now
offer on top of Chrome OS.
This allows you to curate and
publish your own Google Play
Store for your Chrome OS users.
It allows them to
download applications.
Or you can also force install
these applications on users.
And we have a lot of
enterprise integrations.
We just recently announced more
EMM partnerships in this space.
So you can, if you
would like, continue
to leverage the
control panel and add
these end-user computing
capabilities on top of it.
Or if you have an existing
end-user computing policy
manager, you can continue
to use that as well.
We've partnered
recently with VMware
from their AirWatch product
along with some next-generation
providers, like Cisco
Meraki, Maas360,
and some other
providers as well.
And if you're using existing
Active Directory integration
today with your Google
control panel for G Suite,
that carries directly
over to the devices.
So whether you're using a
single sign-on provider,
you can also leverage that
single sign-on provider
to directly log into
these workstations
and not have to worry
about setting up
a whole different policy
to manage these devices.
And really, I
talked a little bit
about how we're helping
organizations drive down costs
by going towards Chrome OS.
There's the easy
part of things, which
is these are generally
lower-cost devices.
So compared to what we're
seeing in the marketplace,
most devices that we're
seeing are actually
under the cost of
what they're seeing
from existing either
Windows or Mac workstations.
The software licenses
are actually cheaper.
So as I said, there's just
the Chrome Enterprise license.
We're not requiring
that you go out
and you license a
firewall vendor,
you're licensing an anti-virus
vendor, an anti-malware,
an encryption vendor.
There's none of
those added costs.
So you can actually drive down
your software licensing costs
by leveraging this
platform as well.
These are built to
be a mobile platform.
Think of them very similarly
to your mobile devices.
So we're very conscious
of power consumption
and making sure we're keeping
that as low as possible.
So we're actually seeing
reduced power costs as well.
And from a support perspective,
I brought that up earlier.
So think of the
time and money that
goes into re-imaging
workstations,
redeploying new workstations.
Chrome OS devices are really
meant to be shareable.
It comes from their
legacy in education
where thousands of students
may share thousands of devices.
And you want to be able
to swap those in between.
And we think that that's
exactly what our enterprise
customers are asking for--
so the ability to quickly
set up a workstation,
get a user up and
running immediately
without the time
and maintenance that
goes into re-imaging
a workstation
and giving them something with
less capability than they're
used to today, and then
administrative costs.
This is a platform that's
built to be easy to manage.
Hopefully, you see the same
capabilities with our G Suite
platform today.
So again, leveraging to
that cloud-based console--
there's not a lot of agents
that you have to install.
We're not asking for a lot of
different integration points
here.
And it's tightly coupled
with the investment
that you've already made in
G Suite today-- so leveraging
those management capabilities on
top of this end-user computing
device as well.
And then economic benefits--
so increased productivity.
We are wildly focused on
making sure users are becoming
as productive as possible
as quickly as possible
on top of these devices.
So if you've ever interacted
with a Chrome OS device,
you know that they're
quick to boot.
Some average between
six to eight seconds.
That is the same
whether the device
is booting for the first time,
booting after the users use
the workstation for a while,
or booting after, let's say,
an update that's just come down.
So think about some
of the workstations
that you use today.
I just recently had to
update an existing device
that I had that was running on
a different operating system.
And that single
little update that
had to be applied to my
workstation took 47 minutes.
On Chrome OS, our
updates only takes
six seconds for the end user.
And it's completely
abstracted-- so again,
trying to bring those
innovations that we've
seen in the mobile space
to people on their laptops
because this is what
users have come to expect.
But they don't expect it out
of their computers today.
And we think that we
can greatly change that.
Reduced downtime--
we truly believe
that these should be
a sharable platform,
so being able to easily
share these amongst users.
So if my workstation's
ever down,
I could quickly
pick up a Chromebook
on the other side of
the room and instantly
be up and operational with it.
And then reduced security risk--
I've talked about this already,
but really baking in all the
security capabilities that
you would come to expect out
of a next-generation platform.
Again, as you go out and you
purchase your mobile devices,
you're not thinking about
how do I enable encryption
on the device, how do I
go through and download
a firewall, license
that firewall,
and then license
that AV capability.
We expect all of
that out of the box.
And we think that
truly, end users
should expect that
out of the box,
as well as you as an
enterprise customer.
So we bake all that
directly into our platform.
There's no additional
management.
And we're using next-generation
security capabilities like you
see on a lot of mobile platforms
to reduce security risk on top
of the devices along with giving
you controls and capabilities
that if you want to prevent
things like data exfiltration--
so preventing users from
logging into a device,
prevent users from plugging
in USB thumb drives--
it's as easy as a single click
to disable that via the policy
manager in the cloud.
And as I talked about,
we're really, really
focused on making users
more and more productive,
hit that power button
and be up and running
and operational as
fast as possible
is a core tenet to what we
do on the Chrome OS devices.
So what we wanted to do was
bring additional capabilities.
We've often heard, I
want to go with Chrome,
but we're missing a
lot of applications.
So we think by bringing the
Android Google Play Store over,
that we're able to
bridge that gap.
For the first time, we're
actually seeing capabilities
like if a user needs to install
Excel on their workstation,
you could actually
install Excel directly
from the Play Store on
your Chrome OS device
and, again, being able to
curate these applications
for your users so
they don't have
unfettered access
to the capabilities
out there of the
Google Play Store.
You can really lock them
into the applications
that are core to your business.
Often, our customers
believe that you
have to be online to
leverage a Chrome OS
device, which is not true.
We actually have
offline capabilities.
So whether you're using
next-generation progressive web
apps or using Android
application capabilities,
we have built-in
offline capabilities.
So you could absolutely
continue to use these devices
if your users are offline.
And we think that if you're
leveraging the Chrome browser
on desktop, which you're
hopefully using today
to access G Suite, that we
want that to be a really
seamless experience--
so if you're
using existing Chrome
browser policies,
applying those same
browser policies to users
as they're working directly
on Chrome OS devices
so it's a very fluid experience.
And the expectations
of the user are
met no matter which device that
they're currently working on.
We also allow integrated
sync capabilities--
so syncing applications
and user profiles,
again, inherent to the platform.
So a user, when they first
sign into a Chrome OS device,
it actually looks like it's
almost re-imaging itself
as it redownloads
all the applications,
applies all the user
settings directly to it
inherent to the platform
and the capabilities
that we offer in the cloud.
And, again, I talked about
the security capability--
so making sure we're
isolating processes
on top of these where it's
an Android application
or you're actually installing
a progressive web app,
making sure that
these applications,
as they become more
and more complex,
that these complexities
aren't causing security
vulnerabilities on
top of our platform,
something we're hyper-focused
in on on the Chrome team.
And then what often comes
up is, I'm very used
to Chrome OS in
education, which is
really great if I want to go out
and purchase a $230 Chromebook.
But it's a little different for
me as an enterprise customer.
And there was actually
a large variety
of enterprise-grade devices that
we offer for Chrome customers
across a variety of
different manufacturers.
For your front line worker where
you may have a more ruggedized
use case-- this could be out
there with a field worker,
possibly in a retail location--
the Acer Chromebook 14
and Lenovo ThinkPad 13
are great options.
These devices are
meant to be shared.
If they need to occasionally
be dropped for whatever reason,
that's certainly
available as well.
So you have the capability
to move these devices around
and not be too concerned
about if the device were
to suddenly break.
And the nice part is,
inherently to Chrome OS,
if the device is broken, you
could easily hand that person
another device.
And they'd be instantly up and
operational with their profile.
And I need more of an experience
where it's, let's say,
a more flagship device.
It's got a better build quality.
These may be fixed sitting
on people's desktops,
or they may be assigned
directly to certain users.
HP has built a
really great business
Chromebook called the HP
Chromebook 13 with a really
great display on it.
That's been very popular
with our customers.
Asus has also created
the C302, which
is a great platform with
a great build quality.
And the C302 is actually
fully convertible as well.
So you can convert
it to tablet mode
to access Android applications
and web apps directly
on there as well just
by flipping it over.
And really, for the
next generation,
the person that
needs the best device
within your organization, we
have a Chromebook for them
as well.
So Google recently
late last year
introduced our Pixelbook line.
The Pixelbook is a
device really built
for next-generation
capabilities.
So that includes a pen that
you can purchase optionally
for the device as
well, built-in Google
Assistant, and
next-generation processors
all the way up to i7 processors
with 16 gigs of RAM--
so really meant to be a
really powerful device.
And Samsung has done
a great job of also
building a pro-level device
called the Samsung Chromebook
Pro.
This also has the availability
to become a convertible.
And it has a
built-in pen as well.
This has been really
popular for customers.
Samsung makes great devices.
It has been a great
Chrome OS partner
and building lots of different
varieties of form factors.
And the Samsung Pro
has been very popular.
And there's even a lower-cost
option with the Samsung
Chromebook Plus.
So we talked about the
economics, the integrations
that go into leveraging Chrome
OS for your existing G Suite
users.
Overall, there is a lower
total cost of ownership,
whether we're talking about
soft costs with how long
it takes to spin
up a new device,
how long it takes
to support a user.
There's soft cost there
but also hard costs.
These are generally
cheaper devices.
The licensing on
it is much simpler
because you're just purchasing
the Chrome Enterprise
license versus some of
the other capabilities
out there where you'd have to
license additional software
vendors that exist
out there today.
When you take a look at
actually integrating it directly
within G Suite, as
you can see here,
there is a much higher ROI
because you're directly
guiding users towards
these applications.
You're getting
the best of Google
delivered to your end users.
So quick endpoints to boot
up, get them instantly up
and collaborative directly
within the platform
in our highly-shareable device,
which is exactly what we try
to offer with G Suite--
is the capabilities
to be more social
with your documents,
more social from an internet
perspective, offering
those capabilities to be more
social and more shareable
on top of Chrome OS as well.
There is a hard time savings
that goes with this platform--
so the ability to quickly
boot up, quickly shut down,
that no matter what, I
always know that my device is
going to be working for me.
I'm not concerned about
charging it constantly.
I have built-in
capabilities in here
where I know that by
default, the device is
going to boot up
quickly and be available
to me as quick as possible.
And increase in G
Suite adoption--
these devices drive users to
really leverage the G Suite
capabilities out there today.
So that's things like
built-in offline capabilities,
whether you're leveraging
things like Gmail or Google
Drive inherently built
into the platform.
And, again, it makes it
much easier for a user
to flip open a
laptop and instantly
get to the Google apps that
they need within G Suite
without being concerned about
all the other details that
go into them having to
use another workstation.
I wanted to talk a few minutes
about a couple of customer
references that
we have out there.
These are existing
G Suite customers.
Both of them have been on G
Suite for many, many years.
But I'm going to quickly
read the quote from Whirlpool
because I think it's a great
use case around leveraging
next-generation devices with
an organization you're probably
all familiar with
and probably have
a little bit of their products
within your household.
"At Whirlpool corporation,
we want technology
to empower employees
to do great things.
Chrome OS has helped
our organization do just
that by enabling employees to be
their most productive whenever
and wherever.
Utilizing cloud-ready devices,
specifically Chromebooks and G
Suite, has fostered a safer,
more secure, and faster user
experience for both
customers and employees."
As I talked about, this
is one of the core tenets
that we've built
into Chrome devices--
that I want to make
sure that my users are
able to flip open a
workstation and instantly work
when they need to be able to.
And the device kind of
gets out of the way.
This is what people
have come to expect
with their mobile platforms.
But they don't expect it
from the actual workstations
that they're doing their
day-to-day work on.
And by leveraging cloud-ready
devices that are directly
integrated into the
G Suite experience,
we think you can make your end
users even more happy being
able to leverage more Google
technology to help them
get their jobs back faster.
And some really
interesting stats
that came out of Whirlpool--
that it only took
seven months for them
to get payback on
their investment
into the Chrome OS technology.
It was an almost 300% return
on investment versus where
they came from before.
We talked about that lower TCO.
But think about
the ability to have
lower-cost devices in a variety
of form factors with simplified
licensing.
It's probably one
of the many reasons
that you made
investments in G Suite
is a simplified licensing
model, the turnkey
ability of the platform.
And that's exactly what we're
offering with Chrome OS today--
and just generally
faster to deploy.
I think customers
often look at Chrome OS
and believe that it has
this legacy in education,
so it's built to be just
an education-only platform.
But most education
organizations--
when they're dealing with
deploying end-user computers,
they're not dealing with
deploying Chromebooks
to 30 users or 50 users.
These are often one
or two administrators
having to deploy
sometimes thousands
if not tens of
thousands of devices
across their
end-user population.
And as you can imagine,
especially younger students
can be very demanding
of their devices.
So if there's a
way to get in there
and install applications they
want to be able to install,
they're going to find
a way to do that.
So that legacy from
education we're now seeing
carry over into what
we're consistently
hearing from our customers
in deploying Chrome OS
and deploying next-generation
end-user computing technology.
I want to be able to
deploy these faster.
I want to be able to set a
policy and instantly deploy,
whether it's thousands or
tens of thousands of devices.
I want to be able to leverage
the management capabilities
that I already have.
I don't want to buy
another tool that's
another server I have to
install or another cloud
contract that I have to get
from another existing provider.
I want this directly integrated
into the collaboration platform
that I've already made
investments in here.
So what we like to
say is Chrome's a very
"set it and forget
it" technology.
So you go in.
You configure the
initial policy settings.
And then from there,
it's very easy
to deploy these
devices at mass scale.
And once you configure
those policies,
they carry across a
variety of form factors,
whether it's a desktop form
factor or a laptop form factor.
And now, just recently
in the education space,
we announced a tablet
form factor with Acer.
So being able to leverage
different form factors--
and it doesn't make
a difference what
form factor you want to use.
It's the same exact
policies being applied.
It just depends on
what capabilities
that platform has which policies
are actually going to apply.
But as next-generation
Chrome OS devices come out,
you'll be able to
instantly adopt those.
So when the Pixelbook came out,
if you were an existing Chrome
OS customer, you would
just purchase a Pixelbook.
You enroll it into
your domain as long
as you have a
management license,
and the device is fully managed.
That's it-- no new
image to build,
no additional capabilities
they have to go through and be
concerned about.
It's very easy to use,
next-generation devices
built directly in.
And another great
reference customer
you may have heard of previously
is a company called Sanmina
that does manufacturing.
And they're been a really
great G Suite customer as well.
And I just want to read you
a quick quote from them.
"Chrome is empowering
everyone in the organization
to be a cloud worker.
With the help of
Chrome OS, we're
a lot more efficient
and a lot more secure
than we were before."
Cloud worker is at the
core of what we're focused
on here on the Chrome team.
We want to deliver
next-generation computing
capabilities.
So we want to be able to adopt
the next great thing that
comes out from an
application standpoint,
whether that's progressive
web apps or mobile apps.
So by tightly integrating and
listening to our customers
and understanding
how do we do things
like fill in application gaps--
we've heard from customers
that sometimes, I need
to run a legacy application.
I need to deploy
an SAP application.
Help me do that.
So we have existing partnerships
out there with organizations
like Citrix or VMware to be able
to deploy these applications
virtually on the platform or,
again, offering the full Google
Play ecosystem of
applications out there
as well built directly
into the platform
and fully managed via the
G Suite management console.
And to get started from here,
if you have an existing G Suite
account manager, feel free
to reach out to him or her
to inquire about
these capabilities.
As a G Suite customer,
you can instantly
go out there and download
Chrome Enterprise licenses.
So if you want to try this and
haven't tried it previously,
it's as easy from your
management console to just try.
If you go under
your Licensing tab,
you'll see an option to start
a Chrome Enterprise trial
license.
We'd love to talk
to you and your team
about next-generation
computing capabilities.
So now, stay tuned for a
live question and answer.
And we will be back
in less than a minute.
Thanks.
I'm now going to take us
through the question and answer
portion of this and get to
all the questions they had.
And there's some really
great ones here today.
So I'm going to start
with question number one.
"To get all of the support
mentioned, does the hardware
have to be Google
hardware or can it
be a Chromebook from any
device manufacturer?"
So to get the policies
that I talked about,
management through the
management console,
or leveraging existing
EMM partners like VMware
with their AirWatch
platform, you
can use any Chrome OS device
that's out there today.
So it does not have to
be Google manufactured.
You can go and procure from
your favorite hardware vendor--
a Lenovo, an HP, whatever your
favorite hardware is out there.
You can take that and enroll
it to your management console
and get the same level of
management capabilities
on top of it.
At the end of the day,
choosing a Chromebook
comes down to your
favorite manufacturer
and the type of hardware
specs that you're looking for.
You make that choice and
you'll have the same level
of capability no matter which
manufacturer you choose.
"What kind of off-device log
aggregation is available?"
So being cloud
connected gives us
the ability to really
aggregate a lot
of the data that end users--
what their interactions
are with the device,
what the current status
is of the device.
So if you're coming from
the G Suite side of things,
you're used to being able to
leverage our APIs to pull off
different pieces of
G Suite information.
And you can leverage
that same capability
to actually use our
Chrome OS device inventory
API that would allow you to
actually pull information
directly from the
management console.
And we're constantly looking at
ways to innovate in this space
and bring additional
logging capabilities.
But keep in mind, there
is a full asset management
tool that is built directly
into this management console.
So you can see the
status of your devices
the last time they were
used, all the way down
to the hard disk
current utilization
down to the CPU temperature--
so really granular asset
management capabilities built
directly into the device.
"Is local storage
on a Chromebook
encrypted, and how
is it encrypted?"
So Chrome devices by
default are encrypted.
Every single Chrome OS device
currently available out there,
whether we're talking
about a Chromebox, list
price in the mid $100s, to
the flagship Pixelbook device,
every single one has to
be built to our reference.
And that reference absolutely
includes encryption capability
with a built-in TPM.
That means we have
encryption all the way down
to the operating
system, the hard drives,
all the way up to the
individual user profiles.
So as a new user starts
to use the device,
they'll be encrypted
by default as well.
And there's nothing else that
you have to additionally set up
on top of the platform.
It comes baked directly in.
So there is no such thing
as an unencrypted Chrome OS
device that would be
enrolled to your domain.
Something else to keep in
mind is that all the policy
capabilities are cached
locally on that device
as well-- so, again, leveraging
that encryption that's
built in inherently to it.
And then you can also
control full capability--
so making sure
users aren't taking,
let's say, an
unencrypted thumb drive
and plugging that into
the side of the device.
You have the capability
of making sure
that that's disabled from a
policy perspective as well.
"With Chrome Enterprise, can
you download the Chrome OS
version?"
The answer is yes with a little
bit of a star at the end of it.
So at any point,
if you ever need
to roll back a device or
factory reset a device,
we absolutely have
those capabilities.
Again, this is meant to be a
very easy platform to scale.
So if you're ever
at the point-- let's
say you're testing
something in our latest
beta channel or
developer channel
and you want to roll back to
the previous stable version,
it's as easy as
taking a thumb drive,
plugging it directly
into a Chrome OS device,
and running the
recovery utility.
And the recovery
utility will actually
flash a new version of
the OS to the thumb drive.
And then it's as easy as
about a five-minute procedure
on the device to actually roll
it back to a previous version.
And we're continuing
to look in this space
and see ways that we can better
improve that for our customers
as well.
"How effective are
Chromebooks offline?"
It depends.
It comes down to what
the applications are
and what kind of data
that they're looking for.
Like any other traditional
web application,
if the user's
expecting to be online,
the offline capabilities
are going to be fractured.
But we have offline capabilities
across G Suite built directly
into the platform.
So whether that's Gmail,
Calendar, or Google Drive,
you have that built in.
Also, keep in mind that if
you're leveraging things within
the Android ecosystem-- so
you're putting Google Play
applications directly
on these devices--
a lot of those applications
leverage offline capability.
It's a very popular
use case, especially
in the personal
world where people
want to use some
type of application
out there to
download movies when
they're offline on an airplane.
So offline access is completely
supported on these devices.
And it comes down
to the applications
and how they're trying
to look for data.
And certainly, we as
your technical team
can go through your
list of applications
and figure out
offline capabilities,
making sure those could be
leveraged on top of Chrome OS
as well.
I will also note that there
are HTML5 offline capabilities
built into the platform as well.
So if there's existing
HTML5 offline applications
that you are using,
those will continue
to work on this platform.
And those are baked in.
So it's usually no user has to
go in and do any interaction
or download an application.
It's usually they just use the
web app as they're normally
used to, and that data will
be available offline to them.
"What are some of the
top security policies
that IT utilizes the most
in the admin console?"
So last I checked,
I believe we have
over 250 different policies
inside the management console.
So it's always a lot
to go through there.
But I'll focus in on
some of the key use cases
and what we've seen from
a policy perspective.
So a very popular
policy we often see
is just directly at
the sign on, which
is if I'm leveraging single
sign-on capabilities,
I want to be able to make sure
that that Chrome OS device has
access to that SSO provider.
So if you're using a third
party that's not Google,
setting that policy
is very, very popular
for Enterprise customers.
Also, a very popular
device setting
is something called
"ephemeral mode."
What that means is users log in
and interact with the device.
They're downloading
applications,
let's say from the
curated Google Play Store,
or they have other capabilities,
they're downloading documents.
Ephemeral means when that
user leaves their session,
it's automatically going
to wipe that session.
So that's very, very
popular, especially
in regulated industries.
From there, the most
popular is really
limiting the set
of applications--
so making sure users aren't
going out and downloading
applications they
shouldn't be using.
So going through,
whitelisting and blacklisting
certain applications,
extensions, and Google Play
applications directly in
the management console
is very, very popular as well.
And then from there, a
lot of browser settings
are very, very popular
for our customers.
So that's things like
disabling incognito mode,
possibly whitelisting and
blacklisting certain URLs
to access or certain
URLs that have access
to things like notifications
in the platform
are very, very popular.
We see a lot of
browser utilization,
and that's a very
popular setting
that users have available
to them in the management
console as well.
But thank you very much
for your questions.
Please tune in next Tuesday
for the next Cloud OnAir.
Take care.